Thanksgiving to my American Dragons We already had our
Thanksgiving last month But I know today is your
Thanksgiving now But yes, today we are playing pets It's a
very nostalgic type of game for me I played a lot of the
pets games growing up I think I played pets 3, 4, and 5
growing up 5 was my favorite because at the most options
Also, I'm here in the backyard the main adoption agency
because random dogs and cats keep coming in and i'm like no
not yet and it's also very annoying too uh today i'm feeling
very lazy i think it's this week this week i'm feeling very
it was like a very uh lazy type of week for me my brain is
running by um one kilobyte per second right now which is not
a lot uh it's it's actually it's like going like i think my
brain is a floppy disk at the moment so um it's not going
for those who don't know what floppy disk that is basically
like a usb stick but with like one third of a memory of not
even one third one fifth of a memory of a usb stick for
those who don't know what usb sticks are it's like a it's
like a hard drive but like one out of one out of a thousand
space of a hard drive for those don't know what hard drive
is it's like an sdd but one out of a two thousandth worth of
an ssd space um so i think i got all the generations in in
on the i got all i've got all the generations in on the joke
uh what is it for those who don't know what solid state
drive i'm so inclusive i know Um, for those who don't know
what a solid state drive is, it is like a Google Drive
space, but like, um, I guess like, but Google Drive has less
space than an SSD, I guess.
She is reminding us what a floppy disk is, as if our average
age isn't above 30.
Thank you for the super chat, Betty.
Thank you, thank you.
Um, anyway, so, um, like I said, this week, I really wanted
to play.
games that I gives me comfort and I did I grew up with you
know like for those uh whose parents would buy random games
at Costco uh these are one of the games my parents like like
my parents would um buy for me uh so um and I used to love
playing pets uh growing up um I didn't know what the fuck I
was doing I didn't realize you could breed the pets until
later on when I was like a lot did was just like okay this
is really fucked up okay i'm gonna okay this is what i would
do so this is the adopt i know it's so fast like i it would
usually on the cd rom it would take like 20 years for me to
load in between spaces i know it's so fucking fast um so
what let's let's get that in here okay that's not that get
out of here you're not that get out so this is what i would
do i would all right that's not dead oh oh oh guys you did
not i didn't do anything to that dog i did all right let's
get dad in here okay come on i need just get where there he
is okay this is what i
don't judge me do not judge me it was a video game and i
would be like whoa I was a kid, mind you.
I was a child.
He's crying.
Look how angry he is.
And then I would be like, whoa, where did he go?
Oh, my God.
He's okay, guys.
He's okay.
He's, why would you?
Look, he's so killing him.
Oh, you like that.
Don't, oh, hey there.
Hey, so let us.
Every.
Look, look.
He's okay.
Get out of here.
This is not.
your show okay anyway so um no he's not look see look see
here you want a little milk you don't want some yeah that's
it yeah you want some milk oh that's right come on come on
dad gets all there you go yeah you like the milk there we go
there you go look see he's so happy looking at him sucking
on that milk he's so happy now no more milk no more milk for
you anyway you could put him up here Oh, and then watch
this.
I'll get a cat in here.
I don't care what cat.
I usually okay Uh, oh, I would get this cat.
Um, anyway, it's surprising.
They're not cats and dogs don't really like each other that
much.
So anyway, I used to play this game a lot growing up.
Um, I had, you know, I did have pet dogs growing up as well,
but instead of, you know, playing with my dog, I would play
with my virtual dog, uh, and my virtual cats and my
virtuals.
Oh my god, look, they hate each other.
so cute.
He's so, yes, because there's an angry cat down there.
Of course he's sad.
No, he's so scared.
Yes, because look at him, this cat is evil.
Why is he sad?
Because this cat's evil.
Look at him.
Wow.
You get him.
All right, here.
All right.
Here, be friends.
Oh, don't come back.
Come back.
I'm just like, I didn't want you.
No.
I didn't don't come back No, you're not I remember you were
in female Dad, come back Where is he?
Wait, wait, wait I'll come back then Oh my god, you were a
male I remember you being a male Okay, no, come on Please
dad, come back Please, I didn't mean it Come back, please
No, where is he?
Where is he?
Where's my dad?
Where's my good boy?
Yeah, you got to get fat arrested.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Where is he?
Where did he go?
Why is he coming back?
Why is he coming back, guys?
I don't understand.
I gave him milky's.
Is that not what he wanted?
Jesus.
It's God.
No, he'll come back.
Oh my God.
He gave me the same dog three times as when I adopt him.
I'm very, oh, there he is.
There he is.
Look at him.
Morgan, welcome to Tomato Farm.
Welcome, welcome.
So anyway, like I said, you threw him around.
Like I said, growing up, I would play pets a lot, too.
I didn't realize actually make babies um because i didn't
realize you know you know as a kid you don't understand that
concept back then like i didn't understand the concept be
like wait that's where you know i'd be like wait that's
where like babies come from you know like oh and a mommy and
daddy love each other very what the that's a hairball um
usually i would play with the let's chuck the hairball i
guess um but um i usually play with the dogs version not the
cast version because i like dogs You want to play fetch with
the hairball, dad?
No, he's left!
He can do that!
He's just...
Guys, I don't think you want him to play fetch with a
hairball.
He can just leave?
You can...
There you go.
No, no, no.
You're not leaving.
You're staying right here.
Okay.
There you go.
Yeah, that's right.
That's right.
Who's a good boy?
You want me like that?
Oh, you know.
I know your spots, Dad.
Right?
Oh, you guys can see.
That's right.
You'd like that, don't you?
So, this was my childhood game.
I think, like I said, I bought all the way to Pets 5, and
then that's when they started going downhill, and then it
added like hamsters and horses and stuff like that.
And I don't fuck with that.
I'm sorry.
Oh, wait, there's the lock.
You're right.
Now you can never leave.
I didn't fuck with the fact that they added other pets.
I was like, no, there can only be dogs and cats.
But anyway, I later found out that you can make babies out
of them.
And then I started, like, forcing them to have kids.
Because I was like, I want more dogs and more cats.
And then I'm like, go!
Make babies.
And, like I said, this week I just wanted to play games that
were more like comfort games.
And I like was like, oh, I and like thank God for Thank God
for like like modders and stuff for being able to Make it so
that you can play these games now Like on modern PC and
modern Especially when you Oh shit It's okay Especially
Especially When When you know, being able to make a video
game To run on Windows 11 is like a huge accomplishment in
itself so a really huge applause for them to be able to make
a game to be able to work on windows 11 um so yeah i'm i'm
so excited to just you know show you guys one of my
childhood okay we're getting rid of this cat all right get
out of here we're getting rid of this cat all right do we
get actually all right let's lock it up so dad won't get
away let's see oh my god guys i could get a pig this is new
all right dad do you want your best friend to to be a pig?
Look at him.
Oh, I don't think dad likes him.
Dad, do you not want your best friend to be a pig?
He's just like, what the fuck is that?
Pigs are food, not friends.
what the fuck?
Why is it?
It's a pig!
That!
No!
That is a hairball!
That is disgusting!
No!
That...
he's um athlete welcome to the tv no that bad bad that is no
no no you do not play with the hairball you what do you mean
i'm on bus i'm trying to make sure he doesn't play with the
hairball there's no trash cans here right now okay anyway i
don't oh my god i don't think i can fix them all right i'm
trying to figure out what to what who i mean we can i feel
like you should have a I feel like or there's a okay, there
is Oh, we could okay We could get oh my god There's an alley
oh my god I remember the alley cat too Like sometimes you
can have friends Like other people's pets will show up And
then I'd be like Who the fuck brought the alley cat to this
To this To this party Who the fuck brought this guy here
Alright Dad you want this to be your friend You want this to
be your friend dad Yeah
And I should play it.
Happy Thanksgiving, guys.
He's like, who invited him?
What the hell is that?
It's an outlaw.
Dad doesn't like it.
Dad doesn't like her.
I wonder why.
All right, let's adopt him.
All right.
That, no, no.
You do not.
Don't play with that.
Those kitty heads.
This is me.
This is me when I wake up from my nap.
That's a weird.
My, the weird-looking cat is back.
I don't know.
Actually, I don't know, Dad.
Who do you want as your friend?
I mean, Thursday.
Do we get another cat or do we get another dog?
Chat.
What do you...
I think you're stressing him out.
Can you breed a cat with a pig?
Oh, my God.
Please, what is...
Locked him up.
Okay.
Or we can get...
Scotty another dog oh wait we could have cat dog alright
let's get a cat let's get cat alright get out of here we're
gonna get we're gonna adopt a cat and a dog alright they
have a tabby a Siamese a Russian blue a Persian an orange
short hair main kun oh wait the chinchilla Persian okay okay
actually I might get the okay I remember her no no no you're
not leaving you're not leaving Oh, wait, she doesn't have a
ribbon!
Wait, that's a male.
Get out of here.
Where's your bow?
There it is.
Look!
She has a little cute little ribbon.
Look at her.
Okay, this is really cute.
What?
Okay.
Um.
She's so cute.
Look at that.
She has a little ribbon.
It's like Marie!
From the aristocrats.
Aristocats.
Yeah.
Look at her.
Okay, don't worry.
Don't worry.
I'll give you attention to that don't worry it's called a
chinchilla persian i don't know okay either a chinchilla
persian or the black ears short the short okay actually all
right yeah i think i think we should i think we should get
this guy this is the one i would always get i'll get a black
and white short hair and a weenerdog.
Alright, adopt now.
Pet's name.
Now that I...
Oh, wait.
No, I don't.
Okay, who do we...
What should we name this?
Okay, we'll name you Dragoon.
Your name, Doki Bird.
Yay!
Every day that I, Doki Bird, play with pets before, I
promise to give Dragoon my black, white, short hair, love,
and affection.
I promise to feed and play with Dragoon.
I promise to pet Dragoon and reward good behavior with
tweets.
I understand that if neglected or abused, Dragoon will run
away.
All right, yay!
Adopt.
All right.
Every day that I dokeybird play with pets for it.
I promise to give dad my dogs and love and affection.
I promise to feed and play with dad.
I promise to pet dad and reward good behavior.
Oh, they're angry.
Okay, so this is what I would...
All right, so now...
Look at that.
Now they're, look, that's right.
Good boy.
Good cat.
Look at that.
See, look.
A dog and a cat can coexist and be a couple together.
Zootopia!
All right, wait, I've been dying to rant about the Zootopia
2 movie.
Oh, yeah, I can paint them too.
Look at this.
This is not cruel.
Look now.
Oh, wait.
Yeah, that's right.
okay it's pet safe guys it's pet safe okay I need your bath
to be painted okay there you go and then I'm gonna make you
more like a dragon give me a sec this is yellow right there
you go and then the paint is there you go oh dad oh my god
oh my god okay okay this is like I can why were you there Oh
my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, okay, I can fix
this, I can fix this, I can fix this, I, oh no, no, you're
just black, no, where's my, where's my brown and dead dog,
okay, okay, okay, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine, okay,
there you go, I fixed him, I fixed it, I did it, I did it,
there you go, there you go, we did it, we fixed it, we fixed
it, it.
Alright, oh yeah, and then there's mice here.
Wait, is that the right bro?
Yeah, that's the right.
That's the right.
Yeah, so there's mice running around, too.
So, you see that?
See that?
There's a mice right there.
Don't worry, she's gonna start running.
Oh, oh, he's got a peek gun.
Alright, and then oh, why do they hate each other?
I don't understand.
Look, you guys wanna play?
Come on.
Come on, does you guys wanna play?
Come on!
Yeah!
Come on, Dad!
Come on!
Play!
That's right.
Come on, play!
Guys, why doesn't you want to play?
I don't understand.
Here, play!
Play!
Here, I give you a treat!
Om yum yum yum!
Play!
You can't pick your animals.
They will die.
They're fine.
I just wanted him to look more like a dragon.
Is that too much to ask for?
Smackdown.
Welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
All right, don't worry.
I got...
We're going to go to the...
We're going to dress you up.
Oh, yeah.
Look.
Come on.
Put on a little funny hat.
That.
Look at that.
Light up.
And I would dress them up and I'd give them socks.
Okay, dragon.
Let's see.
What was this?
I don't remember what this was this.
Oh, what the fuck is that a wedding thing?
All right, this.
There you go, dragons.
This is.
Oh, yeah, I can whistle.
Look.
Come on.
You're such a gentleman.
He is.
Now I would dress them up.
And then, oh, wait, I can give you guys.
Okay, now you look.
Okay, there we go.
There you go.
Now you guys can.
Oh, you guys can.
Yeah, here.
Here you go.
Here's a little thing here.
Oh yeah, there you go.
Now you guys look like a dragon.
There we go.
We did it.
Now you look like a dragon.
You turned us into a cloud.
We're talking about you.
It looks so cute now.
All right.
Now we should get you some toys too.
Okay.
So let's redo our little thing here.
Wait, what's this?
before what does this pair say wait i never seen this oh
yeah here i could wish a genie ta-da magic wishes oh my god
this is like so nostalgic i haven't played this game since
like when i was a kid uh oh come on do a little trick come
on come on do a little trick dragon
Come on.
Come on, guys.
Oh, well, jump through it.
No, no, no, no.
Oh, my God.
That does not like you.
Like, oh, no.
Bad.
That, no.
No.
You can't do that.
All right.
Come on.
Do a trick.
Come on, guys.
Come on.
Wait, why are you so mad?
Guys, why are you so mad?
Why?
He smacked it away from me.
What do you mean?
That was on...
He smacked...
You did not see him.
He smacked the Ulobe off of...
Oh, you guys want drinks?
Here you go.
Why are you so mad?
Come on.
Don't be mad.
You know you like...
Come on.
Don't be mad.
There you go.
Who's a good boy?
Who's a good...
Yeah.
Yeah, you like that spot.
that's right here i'll give you a human food there you go
yeah that's right here take the human food that's right what
else oh wait okay yeah you know you could put oh how come
you guys can't be good friends why do you hate each other
your cats and dogs they're known to work together come on
come on guys work together Wait, I'll put you in the basket.
Come on.
Be good friends.
I'll put you in the basket too.
Come on, you two.
Come on.
That's right.
Work together or else.
All right?
Be good friends or else.
Okay, guys?
I need you guys to be friends.
Good friends.
Here we go.
The get along basket.
I'll put you in the get along basket.
The basket of friendship right there.
I want to... I don't remember this.
Oh, I remember this.
It's like a music box.
Guys, it's like friendship music.
Come on.
Friendship music.
Alright, we're gonna put this back here.
Okay, we're gonna need...
I need to figure out what I want to bring over.
Alright, we're gonna need... Alright, let's get...
Let's grab...
We'll grab milk.
And then we don't need...
We don't need a paint bucket anymore because we painted
everything we need.
Like, they're perfect now.
We'll grab...
Oh, I don't even know.
There you go.
Love.
Fall in love.
This is a fall in love potion.
So if I had a male and a female, they'll fall in love.
Look, there's a little circus.
Come on.
This is a little circus thing.
What do I want to bring?
Okay, I'll bring a ball.
I'll bring a ball and then I'll put this away.
And then we'll bring a frisbee.
Okay, I never owned a cat before, so I don't know what they
want.
What do cats play with?
I think that's fine.
We'll go to...
Let's go to...
Oh, wait, he's eating.
Oh, he's hungry.
Wait, what do cats eat?
That is just cat food.
Guess what?
Do cats eat again?
Okay, let's go.
You know what?
Let's go to...
Oh, let's go to the circus.
Yay!
Hey, guys.
We're at the circus, everyone.
Oh, yeah, this.
I remember this.
And then you light this up.
And then...
Yay!
Hey, guys.
Is that fun, guys?
Yay!
Why do you hate?
each other.
I do so much.
Alright.
Come on.
Here's a frisbee.
Come on, guys.
Woo!
Where did my frisbee go?
Oh my god, whose dog is that?
Who brought their dog to the circus?
God.
Don't worry, I have more balloons.
Hello, guys.
Okay, at least this dog likes me.
That's true.
Strange actual clown.
Oh, I have some more balloons.
Look at these funky balloons.
Oh my god, they're so scared of this random clown.
Not the random clown dog.
They're like, who the fuck brought this guy along?
He's working.
Don't worry, guys.
I have more balloons.
Can you guys like...
Wait, can I...
Wait.
Wait, alright, let's see.
Can I like...
He's not even my dog.
It's okay.
He's here to entertain us.
Get on this chair.
There you go.
I don't know.
Don't worry, bro.
Don't worry, buddy.
We can't put him in the cannon?
Oh, I can't.
I can't put him in the...
Why are you sad?
Why are you so sad?
He's just like, I don't want to be here anymore.
Like...
Do a trick Come on, do a trick Do a trick Come on, why are
you so sad?
I don't understand Oh, is it because I put you on a chair?
Okay, do a trick Wait, there you go, come on
Come on Someone help us Come on Dump through this hoop Come
on Bro, what the fuck, the stupid dog doesn't know how to do
tricks my dog just got adopted so like dad just got dad
please stop barking at this cat dad please that is your
friend you guys are forced to be can i like take him home oh
i can't he doesn't like the chair all right fine we'll leave
the circus we'll go to arabia oh it looks very look look we
can wait we can play oh wait Wait, I don't know.
I need a flute.
You can technically, like, lure the snake out of a basket.
Wait, are you guys hungry?
I have...
Here.
You guys want some olive treats?
I got some food here.
Oh, my God.
Oh, hey, there's the pharaoh.
Are you guys friends now?
I don't know.
I don't know why Arabia...
That's literally...
It's in the, I don't know.
It's, look, it's, this was made a very long time ago when
Aladdin came out, okay?
Like, Aladdin just came out, so they're like, you guys know
what we should add?
Arabia.
How do I learn the snake?
Yeah, I don't have a little fancy flute.
My, you and my, you and dad won't learn the lovey.
other i don't understand what is even going on i'm trying to
force you to be friends but you refuse to be friends okay
don't worry we're gonna go to the we're gonna make a snowman
here you go maybe you'll be friends in the cold look at that
now you two can be friends are they becoming friends now are
you guys being friends with dad yet i'm making Oh, wait.
Look at this.
I can make a snowball.
And then be like, Ha!
Oh.
Ha!
Look at that.
That's right.
It's a snowball fight.
Oh, Beto, thank you for the red.
Thank you.
I'm trying to make my pets become friends, but I don't know
why.
It's like, it feels like cats and dogs aren't meant to.
to be friends guys i don't understand it's pets four look
wait get on this get on the sled dad get on oh my god he's
alive guys i swear to god i swear to god he's alive guys
he's just tired i swear to god he's alive he's he's
pretending guys he's pretending he's look look look look see
look at this get up oh there see there you go there you go
he's a lot there you go look see look at him he's not like
he was he was really tired he was like oh he was a good boy
he was a good boy yeah yeah you're a good boy yeah look see
he's happy he's i look like oh here's a ball here's a ball
you want a ball whoa look okay no no no no he's happy he's
Look, see?
Oh, he's so happy.
Look, okay, here, here.
Here's a treat.
I don't want people to think I'm a bad person.
Here we go.
He looks so sad.
Oh, no.
He's just really cold.
Sorry, I was playing snowball.
We're having a snowball fight.
That's it, guys.
Look, look.
We'll leave.
We'll go to the...
We go to the beach.
Everyone loves the beach.
Look at that.
From a snow resort to the beach.
There you go.
They're so happy.
Look at them.
Okay, they don't like each other.
But, like, we're gonna fix that.
Why do the other pets have warm clothes?
And he doesn't.
Because he doesn't need clothes, guys.
It's... We're at the beach.
He doesn't need clothes.
We're literally at a beach.
Okay, you and...
Okay, dragons and dad are like...
They really hate each other.
And I don't know what to do.
Here, Milky's?
Milky's?
Milky's always fix it.
Oh, there you go.
There we go.
Like, see?
See, now he's happy.
He got the Milky's.
Look at that.
Okay, how about you?
Do you want Milky's?
There you go.
Dad wanted milky's too.
Look at that.
See?
Everyone's happy.
Look at that.
They're all happy now.
There we go.
You want more?
Are you guys full?
Oh my god.
You're so...
Okay, yeah, they're all full.
They're all full.
Everything is fine.
All right.
See?
Fetch.
Dad, come on.
Whoa!
Come on.
You know you love Fetch.
All right, how about this?
Fetch.
Oh, that was so pathetic.
Look at that.
Yay!
No, no, don't- No!
Stop!
Oh, I forgot to bring the spray!
Okay, don't worry, though.
Don't get tired out.
A nice fight is fine.
It's okay, guys.
It's just- They're just roughing it.
They're roughing it out.
It's okay.
It's like friendship fight.
Like, you guys can...
Yeah.
Don't worry.
They'll break up soon.
See, look.
They're having a good time.
Okay.
Look, see?
See?
Look at that.
They're having a good time.
They're just playing.
Right?
Good guy.
Good boy.
Good boys.
Look at that.
Alright, let's go.
You know, let's go back to the backyard.
I wanted to plant some flowers anyway.
No, no.
I'm planting flowers.
That's on you.
I'm going to plant a flower.
Oh, you like that?
Oh, yeah.
See, there's a rat here.
Look.
That's it.
You see that?
That's a rat.
Look.
Okay, I can do this, though, to the rat, right?
Like, you won't call it like, PETA.
me for this, right?
Alright, here, see?
Here's a rat.
No, oh my god, there's a second rat, too.
Wait.
Are they grabbing the second rat?
Oh!
He grabbed the second
rat!
Wait.
Oh my god, that's fucked up.
Oh, that is fucked up.
Is he gonna eat it?
Here.
Oh my god, he's still, he's going at it.
He's going at...
Okay, it's okay, it's okay.
I still have another rat.
it's okay oh nice good job dad dad you want this one you
know you want this one too here you go come on play with
this one too what kind of children gave this all ad as a
child it was this starcraft and heroes of might and magic i
had a very weird select oh and uh and humongous
entertainment like freddy fish i had a very weird selection
of toys games that i play.
It was literally games that you can find at Costco.
It's literally games you can find at Costco.
Look at him.
Dad's just licking the rat.
Look at that.
He's having a good time.
Look at him.
Oh, no, no, no.
Don't worry.
I got him again.
Yeah, that's right.
Eat that rat.
He had a cereal box.
Where did the rat go?
Did he get away?
Wait, he let- Oh, guys, see, look!
Look!
My plant's growing!
Look at that!
Oh, shit!
Wait, can I make them have me too- Oh, I need a male?
Wait, can I make a dog and a cat?
Let's go, let's try.
Alright, we're gonna adopt a...
We'll adopt a... You know what?
We'll get an alley cat.
And
Okay, we need a female, we need a female sheep dog.
I'm gonna say I can make a, I want like the biggest dog.
All right, don't try to play.
God, all right, let's go.
Okay, there's so many, where are the female sheep dogs?
I don't understand.
All right, don't worry.
This next one, there we go.
okay um the alley cat's name will be what what should the
alley cat's name be uh female one it's straight out you're
adopting how you already have three pets now wait lonely
pets using oh wait please be make oh neglecting pets run
away more pets can be more fun but it also means more
responsibility please be sure that you're able to properly
care for don't worry i can all right next one will be female
two all right there we go okay i got it i want to i want to
know if this is possible female one and dad
One pet is too young.
Oh, don't worry.
Don't worry.
Okay, wait.
I got you.
Don't worry.
Let's try.
Wait, are you guys too young?
Okay.
You guys?
Oh, you guys are too young!
Oh, don't worry.
I can't grow you up.
Grow up.
Wait.
Can't find any babies?
But you guys are babies.
What do you mean?
Okay.
I don't know.
understand why can't you guys have babies come on how are
you too young let's see grow up wait i have an idea game
speed all right we're gonna set to 300 oh my god it's too
fast oh my god the game i don't understand oh oh you're
alive right dragon dragon oh oh thank god okay good boy well
you guys are still okay you guys are still okay all right
maybe all right i'll make you grow up i don't understand Why
can't you?
Okay, brain slider, neuter, unneuter.
Oh, I knew, oh shit, I neutered that.
Don't unneuter, unneuter, unneuter, unneuter, unneuter.
He's like successfully neutered that.
Okay, I unneutered.
I unneutered him.
Okay, now he's not as sad anymore.
All right, you two.
You two.
All right.
Or another problem.
Why are you two not making...
babies I don't understand come on guys oh I can rate I can
grow you up right now all right here you go I have an idea
all right go over here you and then all right I'm gonna make
you guys older brain sliders okay you're gonna be a 20 20.
You're gonna be 25 now.
Don't worry.
You are now 25 years old.
You other cat.
You will also be...
You'll be 27.
Now.
Now you too.
Should be.
Should be ready.
No?
Oh, my game crashed.
Wait.
Oh, thank you.
God, it's saved.
Okay, okay.
I don't think they were meant.
I don't think the game allowed that.
The game was like the game was like uh, dad, a dog and cat.
No.
Alright, don't worry.
I'll make this other.
I'll make female 2, 25 or 27.
Okay.
20.
You want a 24.
Alright, you too.
What?
But you're 27.
and a 25.
Oh, wait.
Wait, that's reset itself.
26.
There we go.
Now, you two.
How are you guys still too young?
You're 25 and 26.
I don't understand.
Global brain.
Okay.
Maybe a 35.
There we go.
Now you two are 35 years old.
Yay!
They had to be 35.
25 was too young for kids, guys.
All right, look forward to riding within a couple of days.
All right, yay!
Okay.
All right, they just gotta be...
Okay, now let's see if we can make a cat.
All right.
The cat has to be 35 as well.
All right, brain slider.
35.
Oh, my God, he's so tired out.
He's so tired.
oh we can't no okay dog okay all right he's got it he's got
to take a break he's got to take a break all right dragon is
time sadly 35 all right let's see brain slider 35 there we
go all right Yay!
All right, how do I...
Babies should be born instantly.
All right, we're making another baby.
Wait, you're already...
Oh, this cat's already pregnant.
All right.
Oh, he's already...
She's already pregnant.
Wait, okay, we gotta get you another female cat.
All right, unless...
She's already pregnant, so I can't do anything with her.
Oh, yeah!
Your new kitten is a boy!
Oh, my God.
Wait a minute.
Why does it look like dad?
Wait, this is...
Whoa, whoa.
Wait a minute.
Draghood, your son, for some reason, looks like dad.
And, um...
I mean, you guys can't see it.
You guys can't see it.
Don't worry.
I'll show you.
I'll show...
Guys, I think...
I think your wife is cheating on you, guys.
I...
Hold up.
hold up wait wait this this doesn't track guys wait look at
this all right where's the guys i don't know this doesn't
seem right
guys i think you might need to take a i think you might need
to take a
take a paternity test.
No.
Dad, you homewrecker.
It's just some male man.
Yeah.
I guys, I think your wife really likes the male man.
You are, I guess, I have a feeling you might not be the
father.
I, I, I, okay.
Okay.
Let's name the Cat, dad, junior.
Dad, junior.
Never trust a milkman.
Look, there's dad, junior.
That's...
Guys, that's your son right here.
Guys, I don't...
I like, there he is.
There he is.
There's your son, dragon.
He looks just like Israel.
Look at that!
Hello, my wife.
That is not my son.
Wait, okay.
Let's bring his real father out here.
Look, dad.
Look.
There's your nephew, dad.
You're an uncle now.
You're an uncle.
Look at that.
You're an uncle, dad.
The kid is not my son.
Look at him.
All right, let's grab.
Wait, can I just bring the...
Wait, I can't...
Oh, can I not...
Like...
What is she doing?
Oh?
Oh my god, what is she doing?
Oh my god, okay, we got...
All right, let's grab...
Let's grab your other wife, Dad.
Yay!
Okay, that does not look like, I don't know, Orphan.
Okay, this one, like, none of his jeans got in here.
Like, it's just the same dog.
Like, it's just, dad is not acknowledging this dog.
This is not, none of his jeans even went to him.
The mom's jeans were too strong.
The mom's jeans were way too strong for this.
Yeah, his jeans end up in the cat.
He didn't even try.
The cat stole all the jeans.
This is mitosis.
Yeah, it's literally just mitosis.
All right.
Oh, wait.
I can force them to grow up.
Holy shit, he's huge.
He's like huge.
Look at him.
Oh, my God.
Congratulations.
You're a father to a college student.
Oh, my God.
Where did this guy come from?
Your parents are small.
what a unit uh it's time how do i oh my god i don't think i
can like i have to go to adoption center okay there you go
and then go back to the backyard
he's like guys i know he guys look he's still guys he hasn't
moved out yet okay the job market
He still lives with his parents.
All right, let's grow up.
Uh, oh my god.
Let's make, let's grow them up too.
All right.
Make babies grow up.
Oh my god.
Yeah.
Yeah, no.
I don't think we even need a DNA test.
I think we all know.
I, he's still, yeah, he's still a little baby in his mom's
eyes.
Yeah, he's mom.
He's baby.
Yeah.
Okay, so I don't think we need a DNA test.
DNA test to find out who the real father is.
I think we all know.
None of us are willing to say it out loud, but we all know.
Dad, why?
Alright.
Alright, so he's like...
Alright, let's go back to the adoption center, and then...
Let's go to South Seas Island.
Acknowledged me.
Alright, let's go.
Come on, you guys can be friends.
Guys, come on.
You guys can be good friends.
I believe, look, there might be some misunderstanding.
There were some misunderstandings going on.
But, you know what's good to wow, wow, Wes?
There were some misunderstandings going around.
But I still believe that you too can be really good friends
Like I believe it you too can still be really really good
friends Despite some misunderstandings Alright while these
two play I have to talk about Zootopia 2 This is spoiler
warning So I yesterday I went to see Zootopia 2 And the
thing It's just a little misunderstanding.
But, like, I didn't realize that it came out.
The opening day was actually yesterday.
I thought, oh my God, y'all.
Look at them.
Howdy, partner.
Why do you all cats?
Oh, look, he's sick of being.
Aw.
Look at that.
Aw, you're so tired.
You're so tired.
Okay, so I thought the movie came out, like, the day before
yesterday.
And I bought my first podcast.
popcorn bucket.
I've never bought a popcorn bucket before because like, I
feel like it's a scam, but then I saw the popcorn.
So, but I just didn't see it.
Okay, I'll show you guys the popcorn bucket.
I think it's just like pure capitalism and like, it's like,
usually it's like useful.
Okay, but then, but then I saw this popcorn bucket and I,
and I get it now.
I, I understand.
So, then, okay, wait.
But like, look at this though.
Look at this little guy.
It's such a big image.
I'm trying to fucking resize it.
Where did my image go?
Oh my god.
Where did it go?
It's such a...
Okay.
Reset.
There you go.
But look at this though.
It's so fucking cute.
Look at him.
Look at him!
Look at this!
It's so silly.
It was $40.
But it's not, it was $40 and I accidentally bought another,
I thought the popcorn wasn't included.
So I was like, I was like this and a small popcorn.
So I got like two bags of popcorn because I didn't realize.
I thought it was the whole thing was 40, was like $40
Canadian dollars.
So it was like 30 American.
But, um, so they gave me this and I was like wondering why I
didn't think it was weird that I fucking ordered like this
and also an additional popcorn.
Because I thought it was like I thought you had to order a
separate popcorn to put it in the bucket So that's $40 for
the popcorn bucket and the popcorn and I mean it's so
fucking cute look at it Every time I look at him by the way
it was like why was it like a vip theater So like um so like
we had like these special tables and a reclining chair But
like every like while I'm reclining this fucker was just
looking at me while I'm eating my popcorn uh wait why are
you guys mad but he's so this also this guy was literally
okay spoiler this guy was like in the movie for 15 to 20
minutes i had some like zootopia purist arguing me like
trying to argue with me in my comments but literally you
didn't know i don't really reply to anyone um so um so like
people were like um he was actually in one third of the film
i'm like yeah Oh, dialogue!
Like, you can't say it.
Okay, literally, this guy, he was just a plot device.
He wasn't an actual character.
Like, he wasn't an actual fucking character.
He was literally a fucking plot device that was just here to
be, like, the plot, basically.
So he had, I would tell you, he had five, he would have, I
remember, he would have, like, three to four would keep
repeating the same thing whenever he talks and like the four
lines would be i'm so cold um it's i'm so cold i want to
bring my family home and and may can i have permission to
hug these are the three lines that he has in the film like
and then the other stuff was just like
And he was the fucked up part is that there is a character
in this film That had a bigger impact more lines more
dialogue than this snake But he wasn't like scattered in the
promotional material and okay I will give spoilers right now
I'll give you I don't understand why they have to pitch his
voice to I will give you guys spoilers right the spoilers by
the way the fever has more lives than this snake by the way
the fucking fever has more lives than this goddamn snake she
had a bigger impact in the entire movie than this fucking
snake and yet they put the snake everywhere and then the
purists were like arguing would be like um he was very
important in the movie i'm like yeah as a goddamn like item
like he was barely a character you cannot tell me that he
was a fucking character in this film um he was barely like
he was just like a plot point that's it uh because he was
very important to the plot but He had barely any actual
impact to the film.
Anyway, Zootopia 2 spoilers right now while they play with
each other.
Okay, I should go to a world where there's actual toys for
them.
They seem very, very bored.
They're like, they're just so...
Oh, Dad has hiccups.
Oh.
He has hiccups right now.
All right, let's go to the kitchen.
All right, you guys eat up.
Here.
I got you some cheese.
Here, you can have leftovers and milk too.
Here you go.
And here's some toys.
There you go.
You got everything you want.
All right.
Okay.
So, Zootopia 2.
Spoilers right here.
I really need a rant about this.
Like, it's crazy.
Let's see it.
Zootopia.
Topia 2.
Spoilers.
All right.
Zootopia 2.
Spoilers.
Also, there's cockroaches in this game, too.
If you leave the food out.
For too long, cockroaches will start showing up.
It's actually...
That's why you got, like, bug spray here.
Just to kill the...
You can kill the cockroaches and stuff.
But...
Anyway.
Okay, so...
So...
Um...
So there is a character in this film.
That's played by Andy Sandberg.
I didn't realize Andy Sandberg was in the film.
I was like, whoa, Andy Sandberg?
Wait, that's Andy Sandberg.
It's really funny.
And he hates cops, which is funny.
because um you know he plays a cop in brooklyn 99 and so um
no one really thinks about this character because like uh
because he's like okay so they he like comes in one third
and one third of the film um and it's like the plot twists
are also like pretty obvious until um a very specific moment
Where you think, okay, he was, he is trying to help Judy
Hobbs and Nick and the snake.
His name, by the way, the snake's name is Gary the snake.
Yes, his last name is the snake.
Spelled with D-E, like French way with a, with like an
accent on the E.
So it's D-E snake.
Gary the snake.
That's his name.
It's not like, you know, Judy Hobbs, her name is first name,
Judy, last name Hobbs.
It's not Judy Rabbit.
It's Judy Hopps.
so, the thing about Annie Sandberg's character, his name is
Paubert, by the way.
Yes, I know.
The names are getting very creative.
So, his name is Paubert, and he's like a Snow Lynx, so,
like, a snow cat.
And we all think, like, that he's, like, a good guy,
because, like, the Lynx family is, like, the villains.
And, like, Paubert is, like, the...
neglected son basically he's a neglected son and like all
the entire family thinks he's a disappointment so um we all
think that he's there to help everyone which by the way like
i said he has a bigger fucking impact in the entire
storyline than gary the snake because in the end plot twist
he was actually a twist villain and i'm like fucking hell
it's been 10 years disney I don't care about twist villains.
Please just give me a fucking villain that's evil at the
beginning and is still evil.
Like I don't care.
So he turns out to be an actual bad person.
It's another goddamn twist villain because they're like,
they're like, oh my god, we're gonna save the day.
And then Pobrick comes out and was like, plot twist.
And it stabs Judy with fucking He's like, sorry, I just want
to fit in with my family.
And then Judy was like, you don't have to fit in with your
family.
You can be your own person.
And then Annie Sandberg was like, no, I'd rather be, I'd
rather be part of my family.
And I'm like, are you fucking kidding me?
Why can't, like, I don't care.
I don't want to fucking sympathize with him.
Like, they don't need a motive to be a villain.
Why can't they just be evil for the sake of being evil?
Why can't we have a village that just enjoys killing
children?
I don't understand like Yeah, I deleted because that was an
actual fucking spoiler I tweeted about it.
I deleted it right after I was like no That's just that's
that's a huge spoiler and so so I that like that like ruined
it for me because That actually like Ruined it for me
because I'm so fucking tired also we're gonna leave the
kitchen because they're board of the kitchen now I was so
fucking tired of twist villains because the most iconic
Disney villains were like actual fucking evil characters
because like you know Scar he wasn't misunderstood or
anything like I don't fucking care I don't want I don't care
I don't care your villain is misunderstood I don't fucking
care I just want you to be like I don't you don't don't you
don't have to make them redeemable too like just let them be
evil like all the most iconic disney villains they're just
evil they don't care like we'll never i feel like it's been
10 plus years they've been doing it for since frozen they're
like whoa frozen was such a popular movie because hans was a
twist villain they literally did the hans thing for the
zutopia 2 villain and i was so they did the same thing
zutopia 1 was also a twist villain that didn't make fucking
sense zutopia 2 they also made another twist villain i was
just like are you fucking kidding me that's so i'm so tired
of this like and it was like there was like no hints there
was zero hints by the way because like you know how like a
good twist villain they'll have hints that oh maybe they're
evil they're just like and he like basically adi samper's
character did so many good things and then literally Judy
was like, oh, I was so scared because usually there's a
twist and then bam, venom.
And then he's like, this is the twist.
And I was like, are you fucking kidding me?
Like what the fuck?
Like surprise, here's the twist.
Like he literally said that like, this is the twist.
I was like, what?
What do you mean?
What the, what do you, what?
The fact that he had to say it out loud.
that this is the twist i'm like bro like there's not even
any like like subtly to this either yeah there was no
subtlety to it um so um so i was so tired because it's a
pattern they've done this so many times and like so i swear
to god i cannot remember an actual good villain that disney
has done um in like so long because they keep doing twist
villains and like they keep doing twist villains or villains
that are misunderstood and i'm like bro like i don't care i
like a good villain is not misunderstood they're just
fucking evil and that's what's fun about it that's like the
fact that they're evil and irredeemable is what makes them
very fun like
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay.
Have you seen this sentence?
Do you think those twist villains will fit on the aisle of
the last?
Thank you.
Um, yeah, a good villain is just evil for the fucking sake
of being evil.
And so, like, and also, okay.
And this letter thing.
Um, Judy, Judy Hawk.
Okay.
About the rabbit and the fox.
I swear to God.
Um, I swear to God.
They did everything but kiss.
There was one moment in the film.
But anyway, in the end, they were like, I love you.
And then she was like, I love you too.
And then they hug.
I was just like, I am fucking kidding.
I was like, bro, bro, like they're still, oh, they're just
really good friends.
I see.
They were, they were cowards.
They were literally one moment in the film.
Nick sees Judy, um, the rabbit, the fox sees the, okay, I
would say for those who don't know Nate, the fox sees the
rabbit, like, in, like, a gala dress, and he was like, oh.
Like, he literally did that!
He was like, like, checking her out, and, like, I was like,
that is not subtle.
That is not fucking subtle.
Are you trying to tell me that they're not into each other?
And then, and then Judy, the rabbit, like, yeah, just
friends things.
I know, right?
That's just a haunting instinct.
And then the rabbit, she bumps into Addie Sandberg's
character.
Obviously, like, you know, like, Addie Sandberg's character
is a predator.
And then, um, and then they were, like, flirting a little
bit.
And then it shows a scene where Nick was, like, what the,
like, jealous.
He's like, what the fuck?
Like, he was jealous.
He was so obviously jealous.
And I'm like, this is, I, they gave us, it was like, I
tweeted up, I replied to someone, they're like, no, there's
no crust.
I was like, no, you don't understand.
It was like a five-course dinner.
Like, it was like a five-course Michelin-star dinner.
And then the waiter came up and was like, you can't eat
that.
Like, that's how it felt for me.
I was like, there's no way that there, I was like, there's
no way that, that there's not, you're not laying them hook
up.
Just let them kiss.
I don't care.
I, Like it's just a slow burn dokey Um, they're gonna hook
up in the third film and I'm like bro like
It's such a fucking slow burn And I okay, here you go.
Here you go.
This is a spoiler.
I'll show you guys I literally this it popped up in my for
you page and like like look at don't look at this scene And
tell me like like they're not into each other but then like
they're like they're just friends
It's the slowest Because they're like You gotta wait until
the third movie Doki and the third movie They'll finally
hook up And I'm like Oh my god These people have to wait 10
years To see a rabbit and a fox hook up Like I'm like Bro
These kids that don't fucking know what was going on And
they waited 10 years For a fox and a rabbit They have to
wait fucking 10 years for them to make their abomination
babies like they are starving they're like actual cowards
they're like what the fuck do we do like interspecies babies
like what the fuck they're doing with the animals like with
the baby animals and the most like the most one of the most
fucked up part about it is that in the beginning of the film
they pretended to be a married like it was just like they're
like this is what you can have like like they're like they
actually did like a fucking like they actually pretended to
be a married couple of a child for like an for like a bust
for like an operation bust and i'm like bro oh my god this
is this like i don't care i don't care about the ship but
you don't understand like this entire movie this entire
fucking movie was them hard baiting Judy and Nick as a
couple like I swear to God I I was just like bro just
fucking kiss I don't care like I don't even care about you
two as a couple it was just that infuriating because because
like it was in your face like no you don't understand it was
literally in your face for 80% of movie about the fact that
they're they're flirt they're hard flirting with each other
but they're not he they're not a couple I don't understand I
that's what pisses me off the most is because they just kept
they kept showing it all the flirting all the fucking
tension and then they're like hug they're just really good
friends and that's what infuriates me the most that oh no
another hairball dragon what the fuck hey dad i got another
toy for you what are you doing oh he's so tired he's so
sleepy they're just really good friends and it just
So, so that's how I felt about, that's how I felt about
Zootopia 2.
That's how I felt about it.
I just, just let them kiss.
I don't care.
Just let them kiss.
A Terminator.
Thank you.
So, what you're saying is, they're just really platonic best
good friends in the whole wide world yeah yeah I just there
was just no payout I felt like I watched these two
characters like do everything a couple would do and then the
fact at the end they're just like really good friends it
just pisses me off like I'm just like at least I don't know
like there wasn't like it was just Oh!
Yeah, yeah, you check out your friends sometimes, right?
Yeah, yeah, okay.
Oh, there's also...
I need to show you guys this other clip, too.
Like, where is it?
There was another clip that was there that, like, it was
just like, dude, you cannot tell me that they're really good
friends.
you go his homies checking each other out guys okay look
okay wait I'll show you this picture this is spoilers by the
way no you don't understand I'm very passionate about this
because I have to sit through two hours of this just to be
told that they're really good friends guys they're really
good friends
They're really good friends
And this is the moment where it's like I didn't want to lose
you Like In this scene They were literally saying I didn't
want to lose you And then she was like You're my pack
There's no way!
Very, very platonic.
Very, very fucking platonic.
Alright, anyway.
Punch job.
Sorry, I'm calm now.
They're the best sis of friends.
Punch job.
Thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you.
We'll get the non-twist villains when the Zootopia comic
gets it down.
Oh my god.
Thank you, the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
And yeah, anyway, so all those Utopia fans were arguing
about how they're like, yeah, because it's a slow burn.
So like in the third movie, in the third fucking movie,
they're going to hook up.
And I'm just like, just, we gotta wait 10 years just for
these fuckers to hook up.
Also, here's the jealousy scene for those who are wondering.
This is a scene where it was like,
There's a scene where Nick was clearly very jealous.
Because what the fuck was that reaction?
Because he was like, why are you talking to another
predator?
It was actually the fucking the slowest of slow burns I've
ever seen.
Anyway.
At the end, they confirmed.
that birds are real because everyone was always wondering
where the fuck are the birds he was just very concerned
so so in Zootopia in Zootopia there were there's no birds in
the film and people were like where the fuck are the birds
so at the end during the after credits you know where by the
way in the after credits Judy keeps playing the recording of
Nick being like I love you you and she plays it like four
times or some shit and then the recording was like i love
you i love you i love you and then like she walks away and
then a fetter comes in like a fetter falls down and then
everyone was like oh my god friends don't yeah love you as a
friend you know like they're just friends so like i swear to
god if the fox and the rabbit do not kiss by the end of by a
20 minutes of Zootopia 3.
I swear to God, I have a feeling that in Zootopia 3, they're
going to make everyone wait until the very end where, like,
I don't know, Nick saves Judy for the 20th, like, for the
20th time, and then she's going to kiss him, and then it's
going to be you have to sit two hours to get to that part.
I bet you it's at the end, too.
Like, they're not going to give it to you right away.
They're going to give it to you at the end.
Um,
and it'll be a cheek yeah it's gonna be on the cheek too
because they're like we can't show that we yeah it's gonna
be the cheek i wonder how the babies are gonna look like
because there's no in any of those utopia movies they have
never shown two different species together which i think is
also why they're scared they're cowards because if you watch
the film all the couples are literally like the same species
so they've never shown like interspecies marriage in the
movie so they're fucking cowards actual cowards yeah so i'm
most curious about oh my god dragon you're hitting the box
what are you trying to get what are you trying to get do you
want this do you want a treat do you want a brush don't
worry here here So I'm curious.
I'm like, oh, look, he's dreaming.
He's dreaming right now.
Oh, look at that rat.
He's like, what is this fucking thing on?
So, so they're like, so they're like, what do we do?
Because they fucking put themselves in a corner by not
showing two different animals together.
Like, they actually like put themselves in a corner.
So they're like, what the fuck do we do?
By the way, I need to let you guys know The dude, the fox
and the rabbit flirting Was literally like 70% of the film
This is why I'm even more pissed off Because like it was
just in your face 70, oh hey like It was 70% of that fucking
film Like them flirting Had more dialogue than the snake
That's the saddest part them flirting had more relevance in
the movie than the fucking snake
but yeah anyway birds are real finally they're introducing
birds in Utopia 3 not really a fan of the newest Shakira
song I still like try everything more because it's I don't
know it's just like that was like the I don't know try
everything was much more catchy then please stop guys Guys,
this is why I have one pet In real life What about fish?
They eat fish Fish are not sentient for some reason In
Zootopia
It's weird The lore around the whole Zootopia thing Is that
fish aren't sentient So they're like the act They're like
the food Basically everyone just eats fish In Zootopia
Because Stop!
Stop!
I put this up Guys, stop!
No, dolphins are mammals, so they're considered real.
They have rights.
Dolphins have rights.
Fish do not have rights.
They're literally, like, they're food.
So then that's why everyone was like, what about the birds?
Where the fuck are the birds?
You know, like, that's why everyone was so confused.
Where the fuck are the birds in this movie?
And that's what, that's the crazy part.
I'm like, do birds just not live in Sutopia?
Like, aren't they like, do they live in, is it like Wakanda?
live in their own goddamn country?
Like, what the fuck happened to the birds?
Like, I'm so confused.
No, okay, so the reptiles are fully exiled, by the way.
They're like, reptile, bad.
That's why you don't have reptiles in the first movie.
So, like, but then, like, that makes, that, like, there's a
whole plot line about it, because they're like, one reptile
murdered someone.
And I'm like, yeah, but mammals murder people all the time.
Like, that's what predators are.
I'm like, what?
So, that's the thing that That's the thing that confuses me
the most.
So the reason why reptiles are banned from Zootopia is
because there was one reptile murder.
And it was a reptile on reptile murder, too.
So a snake murdered a turtle.
And then because of that, all reptiles are banned from
Zootopia.
But I'm just thinking.
So like, what?
That was the only murder that's ever happened in Zootopia.
And I'm like, what if a fucking, I don't know, a lion
murdered a gazelle because it's a carnivore killing a prey?
Like, so I'm like, there's only been one murder?
Like,
so, yeah, collective punishment.
So it's like, because of this one murder from a reptile, all
reptiles are now bad.
from Zootopia like I was I'm that was like the biggest like
confusion for me because I was just like so there was never
a murder since like I got one murder segregation right there
and I'm like I was so confused so then I'm like I'm What
about, like, were there no mammals killing other mammals?
Like, like, anyway, so, so now I'm wondering, how the fuck
are they gonna explain the missing birds?
Are birds just super racist?
Like, I don't know how, like, they just wrote them in the
corner.
Why didn't they just include all types of species?
Like, you don't even have to, like, include all the
reptiles.
If they put in Zootopia 1, like, some reptiles.
in there then people will be fine I'm like why are the birds
not there like they're too busy flying yeah birds have a
utopia in the sky and no one else is invited like
they don't mention that too because they'll be like utopias
for everyone except for reptiles and birds apparently uh
golden thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
anyway that's really all i wanted is that's that's
everything i wanted to say about zootopia 2 and my problems
with the film um i know what about the sheep that try to
frame all predators i know but yet they didn't ban the sheep
they didn't exile the sheep from zootopia they're like yeah
no she's just crazy but i'm like yeah so what about the
fucking reptiles like you fucking exiled all reptiles for
one murder like well that's just she yeah
but anyway so oh hey there's a crab look at it look at that
look at that crab oh the crabs gone.
Why are you guys so mad?
Doki, it's a kid's movie.
Yeah, they both let the rabbit and fox kiss.
So now I have multiple problems with this movie.
So anyway, alright, let's...
Alright, Dad.
Let's have a fun time with you and your children, Dad.
Um...
Alright.
Don't worry.
Oh!
Dad, Junior grown up enough to come out all alone now you
get dad junior oh you guys oh my god the resemblance is
uncanny look at that look at that meet your father dad
junior and dad oh my god you two look so
Sorry, I met your uncle.
Dad, Jr., meet your uncle.
My wife's son and my wife's bodyguard.
Get along so well.
Yeah, yo, your wife's son and your driver.
Um, but you, yeah, but I got the snake popcorn bucket.
So the movie was 10 out of 10.
Yeah, the popcorn bucket, like, originally I was going to
rate the movie a different rating, but then I got the
popcorn bucket and then it became a 10 out of 10.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Also, story time with dad.
It was, like, pretty funny.
But, um, we'll do a backyard while I tell this story.
Was there anything in the backyard for them to do?
Oh, there's a butterfly!
Hello there.
Hello.
Are you guys having a fun time?
Here, I'll give you guys this to play with.
Um, but...
Okay, so yesterday, I was playing fetch with dad.
um and then he was having a really good time he was just
like uh he was like having a great time like running back
and forth with his ball and then suddenly he brought his
ball back and he started like um he started gagging and i
got really scared and i was like oh no what's going on and
he's obviously he was trying to throw up so you can hear the
sound of like the intestines and like of like his stomach
like trying to like regurgitate some food and then he's like
like oh no no no not yeah not on the carpet not not not on
the carpet dad and then and then and then he was like um and
then obviously he did because like i couldn't move him
because i was like i was just like lying down so i was like
i was like oh no and then he like basically he played so
hard that like he threw up an undigested Digestive portion
of his food.
So it was like a clump of his wet food that he just threw up
And then he's after you threw up.
He's like And then he ate it all up.
He's like Om nom nom nom nom.
And then after he ate it all up he brought the ball back to
me And it was like let's go again.
And I'm like are you
It's just like bro you fucking threw up the play It's like
he played so hard that he actually threw up his undigested
food and then wanted to go again.
Like, I didn't hear it.
Like, just as good the second time.
Yeah, I mean, it was just, it was a clump of the food.
So, like, there was literally no file.
There was no, like, vomit.
It was just the food.
Like, dad, happy Thanksgiving also.
Happy Thanksgiving.
If you're watching, watching my stream while you're eating.
uh yeah yummy seconds yum yum oh but yeah anyway so that was
my uh dad update for today um also also speaking of
thanksgiving uh speaking of thanksgiving um it's crazy how
like i think american thanksgiving is fucking wild like how
people because i never see these things in for Because I
feel like in Canada we don't care as much like I don't know
Thanksgiving isn't as like insane as American Thanksgiving
Because like you guys have like an actual like lore behind
your Thanksgiving But like for us we're just like well if
the Americans are doing it we're gonna do it too But we're
gonna do it one month early and we're here to celebrate a
good harvest so there wasn't like actual like lore behind
our Thanksgiving it's just we're just like good props today
I guess like I don't know uh yeah it's such an American
thing um yeah dad that's right oh that's right oh that's
right oh you like that spot you like that whoa
um uh but yeah and then so I was sorry I saw like Twitter of
like people fighting over Costco chicken like was it the
rotisserie chicken or some shit that's fucking crazy I just
see like oh yeah dad that's a good boy yeah like see people
but like I saw like there was clips of a woman buying like
buying like what was it like 12 rotisserie rotisserie
chickens I'm like what the fuck are you gonna do with 12
chickens I'm like how many people are at this Thanksgiving
dinner.
I was, I'm, I'm so confused.
Like, I'm so confused.
Like, yeah, like the day before Thanksgiving, and I see
like, like, families buy, like, five to 12 chickens, and I'm
like, what the fuck are you?
Like, how many people are coming over?
Why do you need all this?
I'm so confused.
I'm so fucking confused about American Thanksgiving.
UBC, I am like I'm so um, oh, yeah, and then apparently like
markets in America They like they like house price gate
gouge price gouge for Thanksgiving like the day before
Thanksgiving those families who like forgot like our bite
Yeah, no, that's a fucking dog.
No, that's a dog.
This is dragon.
I'm sorry.
I hate to break that is not your son That that is not that
cat is not your son what we did yeah so yeah some some like
markets supermarkets they like literally take the prices off
of the food and like there was one i saw that they charged
like 40 fucking dollars for mac and cheese i'm like what bro
this the cheese better be like some french age like 10 year
old aged cheese or some shit what the 40 for mac and cheese
bro bro the macaroni better be fucking handmade
yeah yeah they price it like and it's american forty dollars
too and the thing yeah because they can they can't get away
with it because people need fucking they people cook so much
for thanksgiving also apparently people are freaking out
about cambell soup because um um the ceo um the ceo was like
oh the soup is for poor people like i no sane person will
want to eat Campbell's soup and I'm like that's fucking wild
but Campbell's soup was is apparently a crucial ingredient
for some fucking Thanksgiving food oh yeah the VIP sorry the
VP of the IT department yeah he literally was like this shit
is for poor people and the people were like yeah the chicken
is 3d printed by the apparently um from Campbell's soup and
um and uh people Americans were freaking out not only
because of you know food the cat the soup is 3d printed um
but also because it's a crucial ingredient for for um for
like some meal some important Thanksgiving meal I don't know
I don't make I don't fucking celebrate Thanksgiving so I
don't know what it is it's like some for some casserole or
some shit um yeah so that's why people are like do yeah some
it's green bean casserole which is a very important uh and
and turkey stuffing which is a very important ingredient in
thanksgiving so everyone was freaking out and be like what
can i do if i can't use cambell soup now like it's it's
fucking wild yeah no people freaking 3d print food that's
how they lower their price um oh look they're bounding the
family Family is bonding together Look guys, isn't that
cute?
You're not my dad.
Oh, you know, let's see Let's see if that dad junior can
bond with his step with his stepdad Where is he?
All right dragon.
Will you bond with your child?
Oh my god, he's even bigger than you Bro, bro, he's Bro,
your son, your quote-unquote son is bigger than you.
Damn.
Come on.
Oh, come on, guys.
Can't you guys be friends?
It's your...
Oh, my God.
Look at the side.
Something ain't right.
giving him you're like there something's not right here like
your mom refused to give me a DNA test you're the bad blood
is real but that kid is not don't worry don't worry let's
take your son to the circus that's what a good father would
do yay come on guys Come on, it's father-son bonding time.
Come on, guys.
Oh, no.
Yay.
Oh, my God.
There's the ringleader.
I can use the cannon.
I mean, the cannon just does this.
Oh, look.
You met the ring.
I want a DNA test now.
but yeah no i think that's fucking wild the fact that like
the fact that the vp was like bro i'm not eating my own
product the is wrong that's crazy like that should never be
an outside thing like that's ever should be that should be
an inside thought not an outside thought
You are not the father.
I don't need a test.
I just used my eyes.
What else do I want to talk about?
Oh, yeah.
Another thing I want to talk about.
This is a nice Datsudon game.
Because, like, it's just like.
Okay, you guys are not bond.
I need to know.
I need you guys to bond.
But because the ring leader is looking at him.
And he's like, wait.
I don't think this is your son.
Don't wait.
How will we get some toys?
How about that?
We'll get some...
Look at that!
How do I...
How do I turn this plane on?
Oh, there you go.
Woo!
Look at that, guys.
Spooky!
Look at that!
There you go.
Now you guys can bond, right?
Here, you have some fishies, too.
That will help with bonding, right?
Oh, look at that.
But, uh, oh, Bubbles!
Look at all these toys!
Come on, bond!
I require you to bond.
All right, and then...
Look, catnip!
Woo!
Catnip!
Something will work.
Something will let you bond.
There you go.
All the toys.
Look, more catnip.
I don't know.
I don't own a cat.
I assume that's catnip.
And there's a goldfish!
Look at that!
Oh my god, look!
Oh, that's cute.
Look at that.
Yo, your son hates you too.
Like, I don't think we can fix this.
I think this is impossible.
I did everything I could.
Oh, there you go.
This is what I wanted.
Oh wait, we can grab the snake.
I got the toy for the snake though All right, let's go let's
go get let's go check out the snake out It's okay the fish
is fine.
All right, let's go to Let's go to Arabia one more time.
I bought the toy.
I bought this all right
Wait, who's peeing?
Oh, there's the snake!
There it is!
Look, guys!
I did it!
Oh.
Hello?
Are you guys okay?
Oh, my God!
Indiana dog!
It's Indiana dog!
It's him.
It's Gary the snake!
Oh, and speaking of someone super chat about Alan, uh, Fudge
Shop.
They even super chat.
Thank you.
so sad we have lost an icon today the randy marsh band girl
has finally taken down half of 80 of her randy stride i i am
so sad it's like we lost a part of history today no she told
her dad to help her out no it's okay for those who don't
know about the randy Shrine.
There was this girl.
It was, it's like the yellow dandelion girl.
Like yellow dandelion crayon girl.
Where, what the fuck?
Is there a sandstorm going out?
Where like she's obsessed with dandelion crayon.
But instead of dandelion crayon, this girl specifically is
obsessed with Randy Marsh from South Park.
So this is her.
This is her.
I'll post it on, I'll show it on stream too.
So she is she's very infamous in the community for being
very very oh my god they're fighting oh my god dad junior no
dad junior stop
it's like so this is her she was known to be like to like
fucking love randy marsh to this extent and then finally oh
my god they keep peeing like he like you don't understand
the shrine was and then yesterday she finally took down half
of her shrine and it made me so sad because it's like we
lost we lost someone today like she she finally moved on and
it i just i don't know how to feel about it she was she was
like a legend for her love and then this is what happened
it's so it's I'm sorry but it's so soulless now there's no
soul to her room anymore and yeah an angel lost her wings
it's okay those tired themselves out uh she took his mom to
let her child have a tantrum while talking to her friends
yeah I'm the mom that's just trying to have a conversation
with you guys while her kid's fighting no
so it's it's actually i was so sad i felt like it just feels
so soulless now like i don't know it just this doesn't feel
the same it doesn't feel the same anymore all right why are
they where's the dragon do something your kid is fighting a
dog do something You're just sleeping.
What are you?
That's your son!
Do something!
Like, she's happy.
Yeah, I'm glad she's happy, but it's just...
You know, it just feels...
It just feels like...
It just feels weird to see her, like, not be the Randy Marsh
girl anymore.
It's like the dandelion girl.
Stop liking dandelion crayons.
Come on.
It doesn't look like a home for a psycho anymore.
That's fucked.
Anyway.
But that's everything I wanted to talk about.
I did tell you guys today was more like a chill day.
I mean like to be fair.
Oh my god.
The hairball is still there.
Where's the trash can?
Two hairballs?
What do I do with this?
Oh I can.
Oh I'll just store it.
Okay.
That's fine.
Don't worry.
your hairballs too i guess uh all right all right dad junior
it's time for a dragon and dad to come back together maybe
now oh i can't yeah oh my god it's okay but you know what
that's fun it was fun giving you guys a glimpse of one of my
childhood games i used to play a lot i hope you guys had i
don't know i don't know i've just loved pets so much I was
literally just raising my dogs and my cats and just like
having fun chucking things like chucking treats and stuff at
them You know apparently we play long enough.
They'll know how to do tricks, but like I don't I don't have
the patience Oh my god, there's so many toys here.
I don't know how to teach them they refuse to jump through
the hoop jump through the hoop Please!
Wait, I...
Whee!
What the fuck?
Oh, it's the pumpkin.
Oh yeah, that's just spoofed me out whenever.
Is this a perfume for...
Like, because I cheated, in turn...
I have a plugin.
I have a mod where I can make them...
Like, okay, to have them have babies, you have to, like,
make them...
You have to feed them these love candies and stuff.
You have to feed them love candies.
Spray them with perfume all the time.
And also, like, give them this pillow, and then you have to
wait.
And I, like, I can't be bothered.
Like, so I have a mod where I just press a button and then a
baby comes out.
You understand?
We have to wait so long.
This is why I didn't realize you can make babies.
Because, like, I didn't realize that was a thing.
the amount of steps you gotta do so they can have a child
all i did was just play with them i didn't realize i gotta
give them the pillow i gotta give them love candies and i
have to spray them with perfume and then hope that some
child comes out like i am not here for silver and i just
want them to like i just want bam child i that's what i'm
here oh so here's hot chocolate oh and also hot chocolate
helps too like i remember i had to reading i had to read it
on the internet to find out that you can make babies and
stuff oh he tripped he's playing with them he's playing with
the car yeah i do control f when i read fan fiction control
f kiss that's what i do i skip the slow burn hey guys i'm
gonna call here because we do have another stream later
tonight um with snuffy on twitch it is a sponsored stream
for girls so check that out later on tonight at 9 p.m.
PST it was nice staying out with you guys happy Thanksgiving
to all me American dragoons out there I hope you have a
great Thanksgiving I hope you enjoyed hanging out with me
today and hearing me rant about Zootopia too while the while
you and dad keep fighting each other yeah guys as always
everybody say hydrated posture check get up and move around
and get that blood flowing and if you still for me head to
bed because you deserve it i'll see you guys next time
everyone bye guys